myrianne benraad bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
le disait quelques 25 millions
d'irakiens se sont rendus aux urnes et
déjà on constate une participation
faible 41 % de taux de participation
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'expliquer ce
matin
la participation était assez faible
parce que tout simplement parce que le
processus politique
est largement discrédité en 2020 bien
quand je parle de processus politique je
fais référence à ce qui a été lancé à
partir de 2005 donc il est maintenant
plus de quinze ans c'est à dire la
rédaction d'une nouvelle constitution et
les premières élections législatives
post saddam hussein est systématiquement
ces élections parlementaires n'ont
jamais rien donné de concret en terme de
reconstruction puisque ce terme était au
centre de votre reportage et il revient
systématiquement au coeur des débats la
reconstruction n'a toujours pas eu lieu
et les irakiens sans la de cette guerre
de cette absence de changement de la
corruption qui go qui est une véritable
plaie pour l'ensemble du pays les
institutions mais aussi qu'il bien sûr
freine les projets de reconstruction et
tout cela n'est pas nouveau on nous
répète d'élections d'élections et donc
les irakiens qui ne voit aucun
changement les plus tôt dégradation de
leurs conditions de vie et qui attendent
des réformes concrètes et bien ne vont
même plus voter en se disant finalement
que voter ne sert à rien sauf perpétuer
au pouvoir c est vite qui rejette
précisément puisqu'il va là un nouveau
personnel politique il n'y aurait qu'un
d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs années alors
justement ces élections elles ont été
avancées pour calmer la contestation
lotole 2019 avec ce ras-le-bol populaire
contre la corruption vous le disiez
contre les services publics défaillants
contre l' économie en panne ou est-ce
qu'on ait le goût on est le mouvement
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il y avait des
candidats qui portait justement ces
revendications et pourquoi ils n'ont pas
mobilisé s'ils étaient présents
alors la contestation 2019 a été très
violente c'est vrai maintenant entre
temps on a eu la pandémie il faut quand
même préciser que le colis 19 et à la
cuisse sanitaire a touché très
lourdement l'irak même si on en a moins
parlé
d'autant que comme vous le soulignez
l'irak n'a pas d'état fonctionne elle
n'a pas de système de santé d'hôpitaux
fonctionnel enfin à même de faire face à
une pandémie telles que celles générées
par le coc u19 donc le mouvement de fait
a été
affaiblie et puis surtout il n'a pas eu
le temps je dirais de produire ces
candidats de produire des têtes de file
est d'ailleurs le gouvernement a quand
même aussi fait en sorte de priver ce
mouvement d'une représentation puisque
d'emblée les manifestants ont été
accusés d'être des agitateurs on leur a
tiré dessus à balles réelles foule
rapide à une répression très violente
donc tout ce que la population en a qui
ont essayé d'exprimer a été complètement
écrasée dans le sang par le pouvoir donc
on voit bien que les élites en fait ne
se sent pas redevable envers les
citoyens et cette histoire de
citoyenneté elle est fondamentale parce
que dans un pays où la majorité des
irakiens ne se sentent plus citoyen et
l'impression d'un état qui d'un état
prédateur qui finalement vit sa propre
vie en coupure totale avec eux et avec
leurs besoins eh bien on est vraiment
loin de la réconciliation et et d'un
processus je dirais politique accepte et
on entend parler aussi de groupes armés
qui ont joué un rôle dans cette campagne
vous pouvez nous expliquer nous dire
comment ils agissent quelle est leur
leur pouvoir de persuasion
ou alors ça tout dépend ce qu'on entend
par groupes armés parce qu'en réalité
tout le monde est plus ou moins armé
aujourd'hui en irak les tribus sont
armés alors si vous faites référence aux
milices chiites il est vrai que ses
ministres aujourd'hui constitue un état
dans l'état
puisqu'elles ont
renforcer leur pouvoir après la chute de
saddam hussein en concurrençant
d'ailleurs directement l'état central
elles ont joué un rôle de premier plan
dans la défaite de l'état islamique
entre 2014 et 2017 ce qui a bien sûr
mais aussi encore leur aura auprès de
leurs bases partisanes et donc
aujourd'hui on a une transformation ces
milices en force politique puisque sans
finalement leur parle beaucoup du rôle
de l'iran c'est vrai que l'iran et 16h
de roi en irak mais finalement les
ministres se sont aussi sans l'aval de
certaines milices il est impossible
aujourd'hui d'avoir un gouvernement en
irak donc c'est dire l'étendue de leur
influence face à un gouvernement très
faible discréditer qui a perdu une large
part de sa base et qui aujourd'hui il
faut quand même aussi préciser ce point
va perdre le maigre soutien américain
qui lui reste puisque joe biden a
réaffirmé la volonté de retirer
véritablement un tenant du pays de
l'ensemble des troupes
qui ils sont restés stationnés donc que
deviendra ce gouvernement quitte une
peau de chagrin finalement puisque ceux
qui font la politique aujourd'hui en
irak ce sont les milices chiites
essentiellement dans tout cas dans la
partie arabe du pays avec derrière bien
sûr les jeunes iraniennes puisque les
rangs et est actuellement il faut le
dire le l'acteur le plus puissant du
pays merci beaucoup myriam belgrade pour
votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle le professeur associé en
relations internationales à l'institut
libre d'études des relations
internationales et également un
professeur à l'université internationale
schiller à paris